I'd like to introduce now our keynote
speaker let me begin by saying the
following it makes absolutely no sense
that someone like Patrick Sajak is here
at our graduation except that Patrick's
Ajax is a great man he is not here
because he is famous manager because he
is a great man
let me tell you about his life even born
in Chicago went to Columbia College
where he began frosting broadcasting
career as a radio announcer in 1967 and
1968 join the army he was deployed to
Vietnam or he was the morning DJ on the
Armed Forces Radio Saigon
he opened the broadcast by saying good
morning Vietnam following his military
service his career took him to live in
Kentucky Nashville Tennessee in finally
1977 to LA where he was a TV weatherman
and talk-show host
he's been the host of wheel fortune
since 1981 and like many of you probably
I grew up watching him on TV these are
three heavy Ward's the People's Choice
Award and star on Hollywood long the
same I've always been struck by how kind
mr. Zajac is to the people on the show
how personal and interest he pays to
each of them and how he is always good
humoured always gentlemanly always
welcoming and as I've gotten to know him
a little bit
I see the factors on the front he's
actually like that the way that he is
are maybe is the way he is and the
person that is impressive
to our students and to all of us
Pat Sajak is an inspiration because he's
lived a life same successful career in
the public eye and he has always kept
the important thing
first he is an example of virtue and
devotion to his country gives an
excellent citizen and he understands the
importance of education we are grateful
to have him here today please join me in
welcoming attention
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you dr. O'Toole this being a
solemn and serious occasion let me begin
by saying wow this is cool isn't it I
mean it really is I'm very I'm very
excited to be here I do want to make one
thing clear because frequently when I
appear somewhere there are some
misunderstandings and people are
expecting something else so if you came
for the wrong reason I just want to
announce I am NOT giving away cars or
cash today being introduced by dr.
O'Toole is a it's a strange experience
for me I've known the arm family for for
something like 25 years and this will
shock some of you in the room
particularly students to know that dr.
O'Toole was not always dr. O'Toole she
was little Katie O'Toole no Katie Arn
I'm sorry I so confused so and I'm so
proud and you know what does she with
the help of course of a wonderful staff
and the faculty here and the parents and
the students what they've accomplished
in these few years so so doctor O'Toole
and dr. Arnn and mr. Terry and to the
faculty of the parents and families and
the members of the class of 2017 it
really is an honor to be here
I flew in yesterday and came directly to
the school and took a tour of about an
hour and a half and I met a lot of you
and saw a lot of the classes I went into
a kindergarten class which like most
kindergarten classes everywhere was
well-behaved
respectful quiet and like most
kindergarten classes everywhere recited
in unison the preamble to the
Constitution I then went to a second
class a second-grade class where they
proceeded to recite in unison the
Gettysburg Address when I was in second
grade I was learning to memorize baa baa
black sheep and learning to tie my shoes
so for those two the graduating class
have been working so hard the last three
years at a classical education I suspect
it's sometimes easy to lose sight of
what a magnificent place this is but for
the bottom of my heart I tell you how in
awe of all of you I am and how much I
congratulate you all for what you've
accomplished here it's really amazing I
live and work in Hollywood and I also
live much of the year near Washington DC
and in both places the idea of the
schools such as founders is not very
popular my showbusiness colleagues in
the West and my political friends in the
East are very supportive of a more
typical public school they're supportive
only to the point of not sending their
children there you might call that
hypocritical but I certainly wouldn't do
that
I've been doing wheel of fortune since
before all of you students were born
before most of the faculty was born
perhaps before many of these buildings
were built and in that time I become
used to the strange phenomenon of
celebrityhood and one of the things I've
learned is not to take it too seriously
back in the 1950s when the Today Show
was just getting started on NBC
I was hosted by a man named Dave
Garroway and a regular on the show he
was there every day was a chimpanzee
named J Fred Muggs and J Fred wore a
suit and sat there and mugged and smiled
and did all the things chimpanzees do
and he was hugely popular he was on
magazine covers he received thousands of
fan mails people loved J Fred Muggs so I
figure if a silicon pansy can become a
celebrity there's no need for me to take
it too seriously when I go through life
I have another lesson on that a few
years ago I was at a Washington
Nationals baseball game with my son and
the game was over we were sitting about
three rows up from the dugout and I said
why don't we wait let the crowd clear
out and as we're standing there I
noticed as you do you'll learn to notice
peripherally when someone's coming at
you to ask you for an autograph or a
picture or handshake or whatever but
there was a group of young girls coming
over and sure enough they asked if I
could take a picture and I said sure and
normally when someone asked that they'd
get next to you and then hand the camera
to someone in this case they actually
went to the row in front of me looking
up and I'm thinking you know they're
very young I don't and I'm old I don't
want to crawl over these seats down here
so there was an awkward moment while we
were all trying to figure out how to
handle the situation when my son leaned
over to me and said dad they want you to
take their picture they had no idea
one must be humble so I've got use of
celebrityhood I've also gotten used to
be on television in front of millions of
people I don't think much about it now
but that's not true of most of our
players and as a result sometimes they
nervousness will say silly things we had
one case and this had nothing to do with
nerves it was something else and this
would not have happened if this player
had been educated in this place it was
during a college week of all things and
a young man a college junior as I recall
was working on the puzzle which was as
follows mythological hero Achilles and
he was struggling and all the letters
got up there so all he had to do was
read it he said and I quote mythological
hero Asia lies so obviously we couldn't
accept that and and look I'm not making
fun because people make mistakes but was
rather appalling was his attitude about
it was pretty unapologetic and as we
went to commercial he leaned over to me
and said well I'm a business major as if
that excused things and and that speaks
to a growing idea in this country that's
secondary and higher education is about
job training and not about learning the
things that make us better people and
better citizens these graduates here
chose a different path a path that is
certainly more difficult certainly more
challenging but as you've heard from
them today certainly more rewarding they
chose a path that recognizes the need
for an education that includes as the
mission statement here says instruction
and good character and civic virtue and
when I'm not selling vowels as you heard
I'm the vice chairman of the board of
trustees of Hillsdale College and
putting my family aside there's nothing
in my life of which I'm more proud I was
there as plans evolved for hills dales
Barney charter school initiative I've
had the opportunity to work with Steve
Barney and amazingly dedicated and
generous man who feels strongly about
the direction of Education and has
forcefully and successfully begun to do
something about it we were just at the
spring commencement the meeting of the
board meeting and you should know that
every board member every member of the
staff faculty at Hillsdale and some of
whom you heard are here today really
salutes what you've done and is behind
you and they're so excited about this
first graduating class well yes and when
you're asked to give a commencement
address the first thing you think about
is what can you possibly tell these
young men and women that they don't
already know especially here at Founders
we're simply because you chose to be
educated in this particular way I
already know a great deal about them I
have a sense of their ambition and other
standards I have a pretty good idea
where their moral compass points and I
know they're not afraid of challenges I
know they have people in their lives who
care deeply about them and I know that
their futures we filled with
accomplishments and good works in short
I'm not sure there's much need to try to
inspire a group like this they have
already been inspired and what they've
accomplished is inspiring
so let me instead suggest a pitfall to
avoid going forward a pitfall not only
for recent graduates but for everyone in
every corner of American society it is
altered the way we talk to one another
the way we perceive one another it has
perverted the notion of free speech
poison the academic environment has
turned the American political system on
its head creating a situation where
opposing views are not only unwelcomed
they are deemed to be signs of evil
intent it is pitted friend against
friend co-worker against co-worker it is
even caused rifts within families I'm
talking about identity politics the
attempt not to unite us as Americans but
to divide us and set us against each
other the attempt to classify and
categorize us by all sorts of
measurements and standards the attempt
to subvert the values of some by
proclaiming a new superior set of values
and to a great degree those who are
making these attempts are succeeding and
the reference are changing our country
in fundamental ways we are all members
of groups I'm a Polish descent I'm a
baby boomer one of the
tens of millions born in the aftermath
of World War two I'm a male on Caucasian
but while all of these facts helped
shape me to varying degrees I am mostly
Pat Sajak I am a unique individual
created by God and blessed to be born in
a country whose founders believe that
that very creation endowed me with
unalienable rights among them life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness I
grew up in an industrial area of Chicago
my parents were divorced
we often struggled to make ends meet but
our struggles were no greater than
millions of others and I always believed
that I could and I would overcome them
it never occurred to me that I was a
hopeless victim of a system or that the
success of others was inhibiting my
ability to succeed envy and anger and
resentment these were wastes of time and
energy I always believed that an
individual by the name of Pat Sajak
would make something of themselves and I
don't mean mean becoming a TV
personality I mean improving my life
making a difference in the lives of
others and growing up to become a
contributing citizen of this great
country today this graduating class is
made up of 11 individuals who have
worked hard to be in this place and in
this situation they are from various
backgrounds each of them has to deal
with the unique set of challenges but
they did it they would help by parents
educators friends supporters of the
school and a whole host of others but
you did it as you move on however you
will find a world all too eager to
diminish your accomplishment and
minimize your individuality some of you
will find yourselves in colleges that
will try to define you and separate you
by race religion politics social
attitudes you'll be exposed to the
notion that the truths you learned here
at founders are well the sort of truths
subject to prevailing winds that good
character and civic virtue are flexible
terms open to interpretation and
alteration you'll be courted by interest
trying to establish an us against them
mentality some of you will encounter
disdain because you allegedly benefited
from so-called privileges while others
will preach to you about your victimhood
and how you must now separate yourselves
from the forces that held you
you'll be approached by political
organizations who will try to convince
you that because of the demographic
groups to which you belong defined by
age or race or gender that you must
think and act and vote in a particular
way and that those who don't share a
defined set of views and attitudes are
automatically evil and malicious just as
they try to diminish your individuality
they will try to discourage you from
looking at others as individuals the
media is complicit in this effort to
label things sometimes entire
generations they love labeling folks as
I said I'm a baby boomer according to
them and you've heard a lot about
Millennials in the last few years I
don't think they're Millennials I think
you're the next group and they haven't
figured out your name yet but once they
do well and it's good not to be a
millennial because some of the traits
ascribed to them are not terribly
flattering narcissistic resentful of
previous generations addicted to their
iPhones wait I may be a mile oniel now
that I think about it in fact we could
just indulge you I forgot to do
something hold on just a moment I've
lost it oh my gosh my phone's not here
oh here it is
I forgot to do this one I came to mind
folks just everybody lean in a little
bit that way all right hold on how do
you turn this around oh I see you ready
are you ready I can't I can't see you on
that side a little bit all right
on three one two three thank you very
much I appreciate
of course these generalizations about
the Millennials are just that they're
generalizations my kids are Millennials
and they're pretty good kids and of
course they use their phones more than
we did if we wanted to use phones as a
kid we'd have to carry around a
five-pound device attached to a wall by
a cord and if we wanted to put wallpaper
on it we'd have to go to the wallpaper
store cut out a piece of wallpaper in
the shape of phone and paste it to the
phone it's a laborious task and it's
very messy as I said there's still some
debate what to call this generation one
is post millennial although I find that
kind of boring there's Generation Z have
you heard that one the 9/11 generation
once they settle on naming you they'll
break it down and tell you how you act
and what you wear and and how you think
I prefer to think of this group as the
first members of the founders Academy
generation and I don't think you need to
be told about yourselves I have the
feeling you know yourselves pretty well
I think you know how to measure your own
success and define what brings you a
sense of satisfaction and accomplishment
the fundamental problem with identity
politics is that it reduces each of us
we are no longer human beings with
individual hopes and dreams we are
commodities we are groups to be labelled
and courted and pandered to we have no
shared values of Americans but rather
would become a series of interest groups
we're told what it's thought we want to
hear and we divide ourselves into these
pockets of groupthink and we begin to
speak only with others in our group we
know how we feel we begin to decide
ourselves into thinking that only the
valid and true and moral way to feel is
the way we feel as you've learned here
at founders the good and the true and
the beautiful are not negotiable they
are not ideals that can be bent and
shaped by political or social means on
the hill sale College website you'll
find the following how do we measure
good it is defined is it defined by the
majority is it measured by
self-satisfaction or personal
fulfillment the good of anything is
found in its ability to accomplish what
it was created for to realize its
purpose for existence as intended by its
maker only in this realization can
something truly be called good
the good is possible only in the light
of truth not true that is often defined
today by personal preference or popular
consensus but truth as it is independent
from opinions and emotions and where
goodness and truth exists there you will
find beauty we were created for a
purpose that purpose has not left to
chance or whim but was determined by our
maker and written in our nature our
purpose is to seek truth in order to
discover and to act on what is good and
beautiful in this life this will always
be a special class here at founders
Academy no matter how many years pass
you eleven will always be the first
graduating class that put you in a
special place with special
responsibilities I urge you to resist
those who would try to undo the basic
truths you learn here and to say no to
those who try to classify and ultimately
divide you into opposing identities
you are not Generation Z or whatever
they want to call you you are Bianca and
Colton and chase and Ashton you are
Claire and Ari or Jasmine and Rey and
Emma you are basil you are Natasha you
are the first graduating class of
flounders Classical Academy I
congratulate you and I thank you
you
[Applause]